à quelques jours du premier tour le
terrorisme s'invite dans la campagne
menaces sur les candidats menace sur le
bon déroulement du scrutin les candidats
durcissent le ton pour répondre à l'une
des principales préoccupations des
français
la sécurité est pour jean frédéric
poisson candidat à la primaire de la
droite est aujourd'hui porte parole de
françois fillon
le discours des républicains est le seul
à répondre à ses attentes
françois fillon a déjà pris des
positions sur l'islamisme radical qui
sont extrêmement claires elles sont
d'ailleurs les plus claires de tous les
candidats en présence dans le cadre de
cette élection j'observe que même le
front national a considérablement reculé
dans sa rhétorique sur c'est sur ces
sujets de manière d'ailleurs assez
incompréhensible enfants ça les regarde
très clairement nous sommes aujourd'hui
en situation de manque d'effectifs de
manque de matériel pour la police pour
la gendarmerie en particulier et donc le
renforcement de la sécurité des français
leur protection passe par une
augmentation des effectifs de police de
gendarmerie de douane pour le contrôle
des frontières et tous les matériels qui
doivent être mais qui doivent
accompagner ses différentes missions
lors de cette réunion publique à voisins
le bretonneux un autre député des
yvelines pascal thévenot est aussi venu
porter le programme de son candidat dans
ce domaine ils constatent effectivement
une demande forte de la part des
électeurs en général ce qu'on nous
demande
dans les réunions publiques séparer de
la famille de l'emploi et de la sécurité
c'est même le maire qui parle c'est vrai
que j'attends beaucoup d'avoir retrouvé
un état de droit où chacun connaissait
devoir tolérance zéro impunité 0
françois fillon envisage entre autres d'
abaisser la majorité pénale à 16 ans
liant la lutte contre le terrorisme à
celle contre le totalitarisme islamique
il entend aussi déchoir de leur
nationalité les combattants partis à
l'étranger
autant de propositions qui selon un
récent sondage et lab ne le placez
néanmoins qu'à la troisième place des
candidats les plus crédibles en matière
de sécurité
derrière marine le pen et emmanuel
macron